c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
on est à lyon va faire le chip ou bi
pour savoir qui prend l'ascenseur et qui
prend les escape d'accord attention hein
syrie oui je suis fini j'ai pas joué
depuis 30 ans alors pierre feuille
ciseaux pas d'accord attention le puits
est éliminatoire tu d'accord si tu fais
le puits on l'appellera tf1 tu seras
même viré le tfc quoi le puits le plus
et ça d'accord ok attention chez il faut
mais je casse les ciseaux donc il ya là
il ya des risques mais qui sont là on va
se rappeler dans une minute d'accord moi
je vais prendre l'ascenseur
[Applaudissements]
taper sur les boutons comme ça elle a
pour cela dû faire leur nid russo c'est
parti on y va c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
bien fait
là
les morts cyril 4
chilipoker
à la santé de tpm p
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]